thank you
[Music]
we are going to finally talk about what
happened with the Ocean Gate submersible
oh yeah
which um if you guys don't know this you
probably do obviously but they were
trying to take Expeditions down to the
Titanic to view it with their own eyes
they have like a porthole you can see it
yeah
but they kind of
saved on some costs if we do feed in a
couple areas which includes like the way
that they
um use like a ceramic encasing for the
submarine it was a flawed design because
of the pressure and all that I heard
that they just used like stuff ordered
on Amazon like the control system the
controller was yeah that was sketchy a
lot of people make fun of the controller
thing but it really wasn't like that's
probably the most reliable part yeah
yeah damn those Logitech game pads are
[__] done
five stars they did it with that versus
like a steering wheel inside because
it's cute
yeah that was my thing I was like is
this just like a gimmick that they're
doing like is this a schtick so you
think they should have had a big
steering wheel I think so and it was
Wireless so what are you gonna do when
you run out of battery exactly
multiple controllers oh that's good
charged up but remember because we were
talking about it like like as if they
were stuck down there and then we're
like kind of logic Gaming controllers
guy's a [__] idiot yeah yeah yeah but
they just got crushed right like like as
they went down so James James Cameron
um is super connected in the Deep Sea
World because apparently he's been down
there a bunch right oh yeah tons well
him going down there forwarded the
technology to even go down so he's OG he
went in a different thing though like
yeah he went in his own um his own
design submersible he also went to the
Mariana's Trench dude that was even
deeper see that'd be [__] cool yeah
that's a long one too and I've seen
footage from the Marion transform and
you're like holy [__] this is nuts it's
like an alien world was it like a bunch
of weird [__] um fish with like a
little lambs angler fishes yeah those
are crazy it looks like if you're in in
the bathroom right yeah and you close
the door and you turn the lights off yep
that's what it looks like so it's just
real dark it's really dark with wet the
comparison though of like like
skyscrapers and like tall buildings and
then the Mariana Trench and how far it
goes down
it's insane it looks like it looks like
it's not even like it's not even there
the building's not so so the main thing
was the submarine wasn't structured
enough to be able to handle the pressure
of the ocean yeah it was too it was like
the main thing right the biggest main
thing is where they they save money but
they they had like NASA and like Boeing
and [__] like look at this and they're
like help design it but the guy ended up
using the wrong materials oh no James
Cameron said because he went cheap on
the materials that's a big oopy it's a
big time Big Time It's death like six
times like you have to sign like there's
the potential of dying there's this
dying there's this dying you have to
like like sign all of them just to go
like no one could sue if anything
happens because it is that's pretty
standard though isn't it yeah even when
you go skydiving it looks like that yeah
the skydiving waiver it just talks about
like if your shoot fails to deploy like
you cannot Sue what was it the one of
the uh producers of Simpsons or whatever
he went on it like a couple times and he
goes yeah I did it like four times well
I think he yeah I think he he definitely
has a picture I saw of him with the
Titanic wreckage behind him which is
kind of a wild selfie too right yeah
do you guys have any like does like if
you have the opportunity to go would
would that and he had [__] you money
would that be something that you're like
if I'm 90. yeah you know what I mean the
part of the ocean die anyways yeah like
within the next few days part of the
ocean that I like is when there's still
cool [__] yeah like that's already like
[__] way deeper than [__] bright
animals and plants and stuff give me the
[__] turquoise Beach white sand a
margarita yeah that sounds sad you know
what I mean but also too with like with
the Titanic stuff it's like
isn't there enough documentaries out
there where we could just like reference
like oh cool that's what it would look
but don't you want to see it with your
own eyes in a way like to see that it
was real why don't they pull it up not
really send some [__] things down
there and pull it up and put on a museum
deteriorate I'd rather just see the
curvature of the Earth right I'd rather
go to space that's [__] cooler than
like that's way cooler or stick your
head in the tar pit I think there's
another cooler uh destinations in the
ocean so we agree Titanic's not that
cool right it's just not that cool the
movie kind of did it for me bro like I
was like I got my fix can't you just see
footage of the Titanic yeah but you're
not seeing with your own eyes yeah but
Leonardo DiCaprio's in the way can't you
can't you just like destroy tourism
right now if you just tell people to go
look at pictures yeah
also wasn't this also like a big news to
try to cover up all that [__] yeah
how they delayed the [__] truth for
like a week James Cameron right they
have uh microphones all over the ocean
floor right the Navy to detect like all
kinds of [__] Subs
um like different Marine conditions
whatever like underwater
um old earthquakes and [__] outside
seismic so James Cameron calls his buds
in that field like when the submarine
goes missing and he's like they said
they detected a a sound like a that
sounded like an implosion like like this
the Monday of oh [__] they dragged the
[__] story out for many many days so
apparently people all knew that it just
imploded the Navy knew James Cameron
knew and then like nobody told anybody
for days and days and days so it sounds
like because it was simultaneously going
on with that whole Hunter Biden thing
I don't know
happening simultaneously we could only
guess that I mean what else would be the
angle like what are their angles well
it's also like news gets hella clicks
for that story right they were doing
literally a countdown timer for how much
air they got left
but I'm gonna get stuck in Wells and
[__] have you ever seen it come up so
often I'm like I guess it's a big story
but like no one gives a [__] and at the
same time they actually have leaked
texts of Hunter Biden texting China tell
them if you don't follow or if you don't
uphold what we said we're gonna upload
my dad's gonna be here tomorrow yeah
like like that's kind of like news up
here misdirection and then a [__]
submersible with a bunch of people that
like unfortunately we don't even know
who they are I mean I don't know if
that's really that important also not a
conspiracy that's a freaking age-old
news tactic for [__] ever it's not a
new thing some at the same time like
hundreds of migrants died from drowning
yes and no one was covering that yeah
like because 300 because they're at the
mercy of what was it like public service
type like uh rescue right
well they didn't even deploy any help
really right but they were we didn't we
drain like hella millions in tax payer
money to like find out what happened to
the oh to the submarine took taxpayer
money for that [__] yeah dude because we
had to call like but it wasn't at Canada
oh it was the Nate our Navy did some
[__] yeah those of them that worked in
conjunction with us and it was like out
of Newfoundland which is Canada but then
yeah our Navy was helping out I guess
but then they weren't telling us [__]
yeah thanks a lot Navy yeah
it sucks but it does make logical sense
if you've got a bunch of billionaires
and a [__] thing they're more well
connected to get this ball rolling than
like a bunch of migrants nobody knows
that's true it sucks to say but yeah and
we know how stories are and how clicks
are like we could we could do a story
about the Titanic submersible right now
we'll get more views than the than the
migrants one yeah that's true
but there's a really funny [__]
double standard with how much people
were making fun of these dead
billionaires like that's so amazing well
yeah it's just like you're joking about
them really just because they're rich
some people even almost say like they
deserved it yeah it's like I've never
said that just because they're rich like
what if they didn't do anything that
[__] bad like gaming controller dude
why would you and I love how uh Virgin
Galactic like decided to launch how now
they have available commercial space
flights for 450k yeah and they launched
it like two days after that yeah it's so
nuts good because you'll be safe up
there
I do want to talk though about there's a
little bit of a interesting angle to
this now because they found now human
remains right they found the the end cap
to the sub they found the like
undercarriage thing that they land with
if you're going to the ocean before and
um there's a pair a couple who was in
the middle of a lawsuit against Ocean
Gate wow because they were trying to go
to the Titanic wreck site and then it
never happened and I was wondering about
this too because like the CEO of
Stockton Rush he says many times we try
to take them down we try to show them
Titanic but sometimes the conditions are
are messed up so we don't always get to
show them right and and you pay a
quarter mil you pay a quarter mil and
then he was they were keeping it
so the couples out there for days on
this like ocean liner waiting to go see
Titanic it the missions get scrapped
every time they call missions that's
cool and that's pretty sick and then and
then um
they basically say we're keeping your
money though
I mean it's like Disneyland fireworks
they don't always go off yeah sometimes
the wind's blowing but that's
complementary though or it's like it's
like going whale watching they can't
guarantee you can see a whale yeah but
they think oh you guys come back for
another one that's what they tell you do
you think yeah they give you another
route it does do that [__] they're like
we didn't see whales today but uh come
back for and you're good to like they
don't you have to pay again
really at least the one I did that is a
really good one when I did one they were
like they're like everybody please look
uh towards the boat right now look
towards the boat please and then we
heard a splash and then when we turned
her back around I'm like that's a
[__] inflatable whale toy you guys
threw in there like do you see the whale
there there's the wheel like an
accountants and they start turning back
thank you guys nice good [__] boys we
did a whole uh Mount Fuji tour but it
was a very foggy day so the lady still
had to go through her script so she she
began the script with usually there's
like a beautiful scene here but today
unfortunately the weather does not
permit but if you can imagine there's a
nice Mountain thank you yeah and here
here there's a beautiful oh if only you
can see it but you cannot see it
unfortunately
that's not it but there's a beautiful
Forest here so try to imagine that and
then every single stop it was that yeah
this is an amazing view like I remember
it was cold as [__] she brought us to
this corner and she goes oh this is a
beautiful view but today is so foggy and
uh unfortunately the weather does not
permit but if you look closely and just
to try to imagine it's like to have to
be the one to say that yeah yeah and we
still paid full price that's like those
Hollywood Tours where they shove you on
a bus and they're like that's Tom
Cruise's house swear to God that one's
Tom hanks's house I swear to [__]
Jesus Christ
you know what's funny when we drive to
the West Side obviously you see all
those trucks I mean those buses oh those
double decker ones yeah yeah and you
look at the people in there and they all
just look like
yeah yeah like what did we do I do want
to go on it though see Grandma this is
why we said not to go on this because
that they were stuck with her and so
they're all just like yeah and then
Grandma's hell into it like into it oh
that's Marilyn Monroe's house
where did Elvis live Elvis lived there
like that's Corey Feldman's apartment
dude L.A I feel like has the whack as
tourism it does dude it's so trash what
are you gonna do out in L.A besides take
a picture of the Stars yeah yeah which
is one of the worst things ever by the
way it's just a star on the ground has
nothing to do with anything it felt like
they're like at least in the Grandma's
Chinese it's like their fingerprints
yeah it's like molds that's kind of cool
but the Stars like just their [__]
name and then they're like hey do you
want to go to like the Beverly Center
awful dude that place they could bomb
that whole building and not one person
would be dead oh no
[Music]
oh